Now it's time for a check-in with The Drew Van
that's been making its way across the country.
Here's Noah and Karen pulling up
on a special Drew Gooder mission in Nashville, Tennessee
and we will see them in a few minutes, but first,
let's go to Fox 17 news reporter, Justin McFarland
along with Christie Holman, who works
at Hermitage elementary school in Nashville.
Hi guys
I know, I know Christie you've made it your
mission to help those in underserved communities.
You've been setting up fundraisers, organizing food drives
and even buying clothes for students and families in need.
That's amazing.
We just wanted to know like where your
drive comes from to help people
and why this is personal for you.
I, I was a foster child, so that just
I was in about seven or eight different foster homes
before I was adopted by the age of seven.
And you know, it's just, I know what it feels
like to just not know where your next meal
is coming from when you don't have
any comfort you know you don't know
where you're going to be the next day
all your clothes are in a bag and you know,
it just, all that comes from just experience for me
That is absolutely incredible to
can you tell me about your latest project?
How were you able to help
out in this last go around that we've had?
Well, I found out that a janitor
at our school that used to work here.
She had become homeless after the last flood
and she had two special needs children
and she was living in her car.
And I knew what that feeling is like to not,
you know, know that you don't have a home.
So I just started a GoFundMe me for her
and she collected over $10,000 and she's actually
in an apartment right now, with her family.
We just wanted to do something special
for you and Noah and Karen who have been driving
the Drew van across the country,
have a little something for you
Right over here. Come on.
Don't be shy to step on over step on over.
Thank you so much. Oh my gosh.
Thank y'all so much, oh my gosh.
That's awesome. Thank you Drew.
I just want to say thank you
to Christie Holman Justin McFarland
and our friends over at Fox 17 news and Noah and Karen.
We love you and we'll see you at the next stop.
We're so excited to be doing this with you
and thank you to our viewers and VFS for watching today.
And hopefully we're lucky enough to maybe see you tomorrow.
Sounds good.
(jaunty music)